It's a great moment for
the Humanities Center
to have Sari Nusseibeh.
Here.
And for me, personally,
such a lovely satisfaction
to have Sari and his family.
They'd spent a year
here in 2008, is it--
2008, no, sorry,
in 2004, 2004-2005.
And before that,
I had invited Sari
on an occasion with
[? Abishai ?] [INAUDIBLE]
for the three of us to have a
conversation about guess what?
The situation hasn't
been solved since.
But we had a very
good conversation.
And I particularly timed
it on a Wednesday morning.
Because it was on
that day several years
before that Sari
and [? Abisahi ?]
used to meet at the Christchurch
coffeehouse, if I remember,
to talk about Middle
Eastern politics.
So we decided to time it, do
it at the same time, of course,
with the time difference.
And we had a really
excellent conversation
on some of the underlying
issues that have
informed this long struggle.
Sari Nusseibeh is professor
of Islamic and Political
Philosophy at Al-Quds University
East Jerusalem, where he served
as president from 1995 to 2014.
He taught at Birzeit
University in the West Bank
from '78 to '91,
when he was placed
on administrative detention
in an Israeli jail for three
months.
He has founded and chaired
several grass roots committees,
unions, and NGOs, including,
in 2002, the People's Voice,
a [? bi-national ?] public
campaign for a two state
solution.
His latest books include
Once Upon A Country,
A Palestinian Life, What Is
A Palestinian State Worth,
The Story of Reason in
Islam, and most recently,
[INAUDIBLE] Al [? shifa. ?]
He was the Rita Hauser
fellow at Radcliffe
in 2004 and 2005
and give the Tanner
lectures at Harvard in 2008.
This is only one occasion,
one event during which
Sari will be speaking.
Peter, can you give
me the other event
where Sari will be speaking?
[INAUDIBLE] this
Thursday [INAUDIBLE]..
This Thursday?
Sari, forgive me [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it's [INAUDIBLE].
I could look it up.
Please, if you would at the end.
And just--
But what time on Thursday?
What time?
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
Still to be arranged, TBA.
Everything apparently
still to be arranged by me.
To the study of political
philosophy and social ethics,
Sari brings remarkable
blend of scholarly insight
and pragmatic
strategic intelligence.
The depth of his learning
in medieval and modern
Islamic philosophy
is only matched
by the range of his
expertise in traditions
of Western liberal thought
and ethical theory.
Sari's personal and
professional involvement
with many significant
Israeli-Palestinian peace
initiatives gives his
view a rare authority.
While fully aware
of the importance
of pragmatic and
strategic maneuvers,
Sari conceives of the
process of negotiation
as an ethical practice that
must be fully committed
to the mutuality and
dignity of the antagonist.
And it is from Sari that I have
learned very important issues
about the ethics of negotiation
sometimes deployed in meetings.
At other times, just
conceptually speculative,
the idea--
I remember once
in a conversation,
that once you get into
the chamber to negotiate,
you have a chance of
making your opponent.
Your opponent only doesn't
come to you as given.
And then the other concept
that I remember is the--
I won't get the words for it--
is that one of the most
interesting ways of actually
riding past the obstacles
that people bring with them
is to put a kind
of idea or a goal
outside of the
immediate negotiation
so people always have a
horizon to work towards.
And that gives a different sense
of scale to where you're going,
and what you're speaking,
and what gains you want.
So I like this idea, which
is both partly a distraction
and a horizon--
interesting strategy.
Negotiation for Sari
is a noble calling.
He insists on the
necessity, however remote
or aspirational it may appear,
of open dialogue, in which
the commitment to
the Palestinian cause
does not prevent him from
seeing how aims, goals, and even
values come to be transformed
in the processes of negotiation.
Even in the darkest
times, Sari surpasses
dogmas and orthodoxies
to suggest that in order
to reach a workable
agreement, there
has to be an ethical
commitment to the very process
of negotiation.
The title of this
evening's conversation
comes from the question
Sari posed in a talk
he gave in Jerusalem
last December.
What, he asked, would
sharing a city mean?
Sari, welcome, and thank you so
much for coming here and being
in conversation [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
You can speak sitting or
you can speak standing.
You can do whatever.
After you speak--
yeah, I forgot to say
we have three photographs
from [? Mikhail ?] [INAUDIBLE]
new book on Jerusalem, which
we will show after Sari's
conversation and just use them
as part of our conversation
and indeed, yours.
She is unable to
be with us today.
But I am extremely grateful
to [? Mikhail ?] [INAUDIBLE]
for allowing us to
use her photographs.
I'm very grateful, too.
If I sat will you hear me?
I mean-- will it sort
of be impolite if I sat?
[LAUGHTER]
No.
OK.
Well, thank you very much.
First of all, I'd like to thank
[INAUDIBLE] for hosting me
tonight.
He has a very busy schedule.
And he only arrived
yesterday, I think, and is
traveling away again tomorrow.
Pleasure to [INAUDIBLE].
And it just happened
that he managed
this particular meeting.
And [INAUDIBLE] was at the
Radcliffe Institute the year
I spent there.
And so we had a
wonderful time together,
together with other
colleagues, actually.
And it was a
memorable year for me.
Some other colleagues are
here, present, I think.
Melissa was here somewhere.
I can't see her.
But--
Where's Melissa?
--there she is.
That's Melissa.
And it was a
wonderful combination
of people, sort of doing
physics and doing this and that.
And so it was a
wonderful year for me.
And [INAUDIBLE],, by the way,
is also an excellent cook.
So is Melissa, by the way.
So I was asked to say
something about Jerusalem.
And in particular, about
the idea of sharing.
And I haven't really
prepared anything.
But I want to sort of speak less
than 20 minutes, [INAUDIBLE],,
if you allow me.
Whatever you like.
And then I can take questions
and perhaps address them.
Maybe I just want to start
off by saying that today there
were municipal elections
and local elections
in Jerusalem and
in Israel, in fact.
And just like every other
year for the past 50 years,
I think, ever since
1967, only a tiny portion
of the Palestinians
in fact participated
in those elections.
I think less than 1%.
Although this year,
there was an attempt
by a group of Palestinians
from Jerusalem
to participate in
those elections.
But we can discuss this.
Why is it that the
Palestinians in East Jerusalem
have, for all this
time, been opposed
to participating in elections?
And what does this mean
in the context of thinking
about sharing the city?
As you know, there are
perhaps between three and 400,
or perhaps a bit over,
Palestinians in Jerusalem.
And you know, they have
actually been living,
since 1967, in a very strange
kind of suspended situation
because they are not regarded--
East Jerusalem is not regarded
by Israel as occupied,
as the other territories.
And it's annexed.
So it falls under Israeli law.
And the Palestinians, therefore,
are residents in Israel,
insofar as they
are Jerusalemites.
But they have not, in the
past 50 years, been involved.
They haven't themselves
accepted to become
involved in any of the--
as a community-- in
the municipal elections
or in any other
sort of institution
in the Israeli system.
Nonetheless, of
course, there have
been also seeking
to find, together
with Palestinian colleagues,
people in the rest of the West
Bank in Gaza, trying to find
a national solution, not
a municipal solution,
to their problem
in the context of a
two state solution.
And they've been involved
in the negotiations,
along with other Palestinians,
in the context of that attempt
to reach a two state solution.
And unfortunately, as
you probably all know,
that process has not really
borne any fruit so far.
And if anything, in
fact, it looks like--
looked at objectively,
rationally speaking--
it looks like it's
been a failure.
And that day after
day, year after year,
we're being pushed, I
think, both sides, maybe,
by default, into
a single system.
But not a system in which
the two parties are partners,
but it is a system in which
one party is basically sitting
on top of the other party.
And in Jerusalem in
particular, there
have been problems
that in a sense
exemplify this
very odd situation.
The problems have been
the slow, if you like,
displacement of Palestinians
in the city-- displacement not
only as individuals, but also
as a culture, as street names,
as properties.
In the past few weeks, there
have been various attempts,
successful attempts, to take
over some Arab properties
in the old city, buying Arab
properties in the Old City.
And this has created
a lot of noise
among Jerusalemites,
among Arab Jerusalemites,
as a way of expressing anxiety
about their status in the city.
In other words, we are living in
a situation that doesn't really
give us much [? chance ?]
on the Palestinian side
to think in terms
of an equitable
engagement with the other side.
Now this morning, I was
asking my son, my eldest son--
you know, I was
telling him I was
going to talk about sharing, and
what should I say about that.
And he said, well,
there are three ways
of looking at sharing.
One is you divide things up.
You have an orange.
And you divide it
up in the middle,
and you sort of give
one part to the one side
and the other to the other.
And the other way of
doing it is to peel it.
And then maybe the other party
will take either the orange
or the peel.
[LAUGHTER] And that
has to do with--
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
--that has to do with what your
needs are, or concerns are.
So you know, one party
may just need the peel.
So you give it to them.
And the other party
needs the actual orange.
But the third way, he said,
was to think of it, or sharing,
as an idea.
And I told him what
does that mean?
And he said, well,
in sharing an idea,
there is no giving things
away to somebody else.
You maintain possession,
if you like--
you and the other of the thing
that you have before you.
And he said to me, well,
Jerusalem can be like that.
Jerusalem can be an idea.
And I thought about this on the
train today to see whether I
can agree with him
and decided I can't.
Because I thought, well,
even as an idea, people,
different parties actually can
disagree over what the idea is.
And we end up, in
fact, needing to
once again having to come
to terms with one another.
Let me go back to the beginning
and then to talk a little bit
about the word sharing.
When I first started talking
or thinking about sharing,
it was on the basis of listening
to my sons and daughter--
no, sons-- my daughter, not yet.
But my sons telling
their kids, when
they started fighting
with one another
over a piece of chocolate
or a cake or something,
and I'll hear them
tell their kids
you should share with your
brother or your sister.
And I started thinking
about that, what that means.
And decided, really, what that
means at the end of the day is
that you should be able to
somehow respect the other--
your brother, in this
case, or sister--
as an equal individual being.
And when I started trying to
think about how to apply this
to Jerusalem, I
started thinking, well,
you can't really do any
sharing between Israelis
and Palestinians until
and unless we somehow
come to see each other
as equal human beings.
Now at some points in
the past 50 years--
[INAUDIBLE] just
mentioned, for instance,
my longstanding relationship
with [? Avishai ?] and many
other examples--
at some points, I could
see that, in fact, Israelis
and Palestinians could, in fact,
look upon each other as equals
and respect each other
and, therefore, would
be prepared to share with
the other whatever needs
to be shared between them.
But at other points,
and unfortunately,
more and more in the past
few years, the demography
of the Palestinians
and of the Israelis
has changed to such
an extent that it's
become far harder
on our side to look
at the other party as people
with whom we can share
and for the other side to look
upon us as a party with whom
they can share.
Of course, it's
far more difficult
if you're thinking
of the sharing
when it's being done
between parties.
Then when it's being
done between individuals,
individuals can get along with
one another far more easily.
But when you're thinking
of the claimants
to Jerusalem, Israelis
and Palestinians,
and when you think of the
way that both sides, Israelis
and Palestinians, have
actually transformed
over the past few years,
transformed to the worse,
transformed in a way that makes
each side begin to think more
specifically, of themselves
and to exclude the other,
it sort of has become
really a very hard business
to try and see how
sharing can be done.
I still hope that the
miracle will occur.
I always hope that the
After all, this is the Holy Land
and one should never lose hope.
And I'm sure
something will occur.
But if you look at things,
objectively, rationally,
unfortunately--
I see that the
situation has been
deteriorating over
the past few years,
over the past 10, 15 years.
And I see that it's going to
be much harder to try and do
something about it now.
Recently, you all heard--
I don't know how
Trump sounds here--
how does he sound here, Trump?
[AUDIENCE MURMURING]
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
But you know I'm
mentioning him because,
referring to what
[INAUDIBLE] said just now,
that sometimes you
have to try and see
beyond the immediate parameters.
And what's been happening
over the past year
with us is that the United
States policy, if you like,
Trump policy, has been trying
to make us back home to see
beyond the existing parameters,
beyond the existing parameters
that we've actually been
living with for the past 15
years of negotiations.
Hydro?
How are you?
I understand it's
affirmative action somewhere.
[LAUGHS]
So you know, that's the
kind of thing that might--
How is Trump making you
see beyond the parameters?
He sees.
No.
But what about you,
when you hear about--
OK.
That's good.
Thank you for asking me.
So I'm better when
I'm asked questions.
So please ask questions.
Now of course, we on
the Palestinian side
are really very
angry with Trump.
Because we've been sort of led
to believe over the past 10, 20
years, through the Oslo
process before that,
that we'll end up basically
having a state along the '67
lines, East Jerusalem
as its capital,
the refugee problem will
be resolved in the context
of the Palestinian state.
In general, that was the--
and this has failed.
Now Trump came along, or
comes along, and says,
forget about that.
Maybe you can think
about two states.
But look at the wider region.
Look at the world
around you and think
about how this part of
the geography of the map
can be linked up with
that, how people from here
can be sort of linked up
with people from there.
And it sort of makes one
think of a future beyond
or a geography, if you
like, or a political area
beyond the classical two
state solution or paradigm
that we've been thinking of.
Now I'm not saying
this is a good thing.
And indeed, I mean, we look
upon it as a terrible thing,
as Palestinians.
But I'm saying
that maybe one does
have to look beyond
existing parameters.
I mean, at one point--
I don't know if you
realize this or not--
but what today-- for most
of us, for a lot of us--
seems to be a very sort
of classical solution
and rational solution,
which is a two state
solution, at one point, believe
it or not, was totally crazy.
It wasn't accepted at all.
It took many years after '67, in
particular, it took many years
until the Americans
came on board,
the Europeans came on board,
everybody came on board
for a two state solution.
And it was a lot of hard
work to get everybody
to accept a two state solution.
So now to think or to propose
that a two state classical
solution isn't
necessarily going to work,
but other things might work--
Can you just tell us a little
more about the Trump proposals?
What are the Jew
territorial ideas?
I mean, what will happen?
I don't really know anything
about, I mean, you know,
the Trump proposals.
But what I gather is
that he's trying to bring
in the rest of the Arab world.
And he is basically trying to
go along with an Israeli, also,
policy of trying
to what they call
normalize relationships
between Israel
and the Arab world as a
prelude, or as a condition for,
going ahead with developing,
giving more leeway
for the Palestinians.
Now I don't know how
far they want to go
in terms of giving a leeway.
I don't know how far Trump
has in mind or anybody
has in mind for the
Palestinians-- do
they want us to have a state
or not, properly speaking.
But I think they're trying to
think of the entire region,
so to speak.
They have many ideas of
linking up the region.
For instance, the minister
of transport in Israel
apparently has very daring
ideas about railway tracks that
will bring everybody together.
There was a visit recently
of Netanyahu to Muscat,
in which the sultan
of Oman was basically
welcoming this kind of new
world order, if you like,
or regional order.
Now I don't know where we
will end up as Palestinians.
Maybe we will ask--
Diaspora.
--yes, it's possible, diaspora.
But also it's possible
that we will end up
in a single system
with Israelis.
In other words, by default
again, in one state.
Now I'm not sure whether
immediately people
will be able to achieve
full rights in such a state.
Certainly, it doesn't look
like this way for now.
But eventually, maybe,
that's what will happen.
I mean, if you look ahead,
not 10 or 20 or 30 years,
but further ahead, maybe
that's what will happen.
Maybe that's the
only thing that can
happen to get the Israelis
and the Palestinians somehow,
who are living in that
area, to in fact share
the entire political system.
A lot has to be transformed in
the psychologies and attitudes
and creeds and beliefs of
the people, the Palestinians
and Israelis.
But maybe that's the
only way to go forward.
So you've finished?
Do you want me to
ask you questions?
How do you want to play this?
I think--
I should stop
myself from talking.
Well, let me ask you this then.
Well, two things-- one,
if you look back 40 years
and you now look at
the situation now,
think of what you had.
You know, the hopes
you'd had, the
plans you'd had for the region,
and now think of where you are.
How do you feel about it?
In one word, very sad--
I think it's very
sad because I think
that we've been paying a
high price, both Israelis
and Palestinians,
certainly Palestinians.
And to my mind, you
know, paying a price
that we needn't have paid
in some way or another.
I think that maybe we--
in some mysterious way
we need to have paid it.
But when you look
at it rationally,
you don't think that
it was necessary.
Look.
I mean, I started
out many years ago.
The first time I actually
accepted a two state solution
was, believe it or not, when I
was a student here at Harvard.
And someone came--
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
came to visit.
And he gave us a talk, the
Palestinian, Arab student
community here, about
a two state solution.
And I remember feeling
very angry with that.
Because at the time, my idea was
why should there be two states?
You know, can't we
all live in one state?
And can't we all have equal
rights, and so on and so forth.
But then slowly, that was in--
when was it, in '74 maybe,
or thereabouts, or '75.
And then I went back home.
I started teaching at Birzeit.
And I started learning
from the students
I was teaching about the real
needs, as opposed to the ideas
that I had in my head.
And I started seeing that
the students' real needs had
to do with two
basic needs, which
were freedom and independence,
to be independent
and to be free.
That's to say, to
have their own state.
And therefore, I went
along, basically,
with the idea of two
states on the basis
that the students I was teaching
wanted a state of their own
and were prepared
to have a two state
solution alongside Israel.
And that developed.
And so I worked
very hard in order
to try and bring that about.
And as you know, I was
part of or involved
in, whether second track
or indirect negotiations
with Israelis for
many, many years
trying to bring that solution
about, a two state solution.
But unfortunately,
for different reasons,
this hasn't come about.
And I feel sad about this.
And I feel that, in
many ways, maybe I
was naive at the time to
think that a two state
solution is indeed possible.
And although I
reject, in my head,
thinking about things
being inevitable and so on,
but you know, I've begun to
think recently that maybe--
maybe-- the idea
of Zionism is not
something that, in fact, works.
It isn't something that can
coexist with another party,
with the Palestinians.
It was at one point.
It could exist, could have
existed, maybe, at one point.
But I think there have
been transformations
taking place within
Zionism, within the state
ideology of Israel.
As indeed, also,
unfortunately, there
have been also transformations
on the Palestinian side,
with the ideology on both sides
becoming less inclusive, less
accepting of the other.
So yeah, in one
[? state, ?] I feel sad.
You know, we had David Grossman.
I'd invited David Grossman here.
And he gave a very effecting
and beautiful lecture.
You know, his view
was very pessimistic.
But he said that we live in
these different bubbles there.
I mean, he was very
honest about it.
We may share a
whole lot of things.
He said within the
bubble in which I live,
I can say whatever I feel like
about the Zionist, Israeli
nation state.
And he was very, very--
he's very critical.
But when you talk, and even
he talked about both sides,
and we talk about the
question of sharing,
you talked about the analogy of
your children, that your son--
what does it mean
to share an idea,
or to share an orange, or
children, please share a cake?
And as you said, there is
a sense of equality there.
You know, you wouldn't say
that because you're a woman
or you're a girl, you should
have a smaller slice of cake.
But what is it--
I mean, how are these
two sides disposed?
Can we talk about
sharing as if people come
to the table in the same way?
What's the point of that?
I mean, do they really
come in the same way,
or are there profound
structural differences?
If somebody comes to the
table hungry, really hungry,
you know, they would see it as
a right to take 3/4 of the cake.
The question of sharing,
then, is not some ideal order.
It is a sense of need.
It is a sense of psychic
desire, from trauma.
So should we be
talking about this
with all these [? negotiatory ?]
balances, two sides,
or are we evading something?
If I understand
you, I'm not sure--
but I think that the two ways
of looking at this orange,
in this case, looking
at Jerusalem, one way--
and that has been the
classical approach--
is to say Jerusalem has
Palestinians, has Israelis.
A best way to approach the
problem of the conflict
between them, the conflicting
claims between them
is simply to divide it up--
not share, but to divide.
Divide it up.
Divide it up between
one side, which is then
run entirely by
the Palestinians,
and the other by the Israelis.
And this is the
classical approach.
So here you're dividing,
you're not sharing, in a sense.
And it's much
easier, much simpler.
It's sort of taking the orange
in the middle, or some point,
and cutting it in
half and saying, OK,
you can do with your
piece what you want.
And I'll do what I want.
But this has become more
and more difficult to do,
the actual geographic division.
And so now people sometimes
say, well, maybe we
can have a shared capital.
So it's not a capital that can
be divided up geographically,
but it can be shared.
But the question is
how can this be shared?
There has to be, as
you said earlier,
for a proper sharing, some
kind of equitable recognition
of the one by the other.
Now by recognition,
what do I mean?
I mean, respect for the
creed, for the religion,
for the culture, for
the national memory,
for the narrative, for all
kinds of things which it's
very hard to do
now for the moment,
which it's actually becoming
harder and harder to do.
But that's the only
kind of sharing.
Now it's possible to share, for
instance, services in the city.
Even if it's somehow--
with the kind of porous open
border, you can share services.
You can share a lot of public
services, most of them,
perhaps.
You can share lots
of things and still
maintain some kind of
equitable geographic balance,
demographic balance on
one side and the other.
I mean, things are possible.
But I'm not sure that people are
up to, now, talking about this
or reaching solutions about it.
When we talk about
sharing, there's
also some kind of sense
of openness of the object.
Now without talking about the
Palestinians or the Israelis
for a minute, the whole
security apparatus
is such that the question
of exchange or passing
is so difficult, with the
barriers, the surveillance,
the wall that skirts--
you know, that divides
people's lands--
the settlements that are a
continual imperial outrage.
So it seems to me that,
Sari, I applaud your sense
that maybe 40 years from now or
a half, something will happen.
But from everything
you have said--
Something good.
--something good will happen.
But from everything you've
said over the past 40 years,
and indeed, the
trough now, it seems
very difficult to imagine.
So what is this
dream of progress?
Of course, one has
to live that dream.
But are there small instances
of the local state or local
initiatives that
would give us hope?
Because what you just said
about today's election,
where less than
1% of Palestinians
are represented
in the municipal--
Participating.
--or participated in
the municipal election--
I mean, that's,
like, a disaster.
And people do say-- by the
way, I was in Germany recently
and the people from Haifa--
people do say that there is some
sense in Haifa of there being,
at least at the level
of the civil society,
groups that meet with
some element of equality
in their discussions of that.
I'm sure that happens
in [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm sure it happens in Tel Aviv.
But none of it seems to
impact on the structure.
Yeah.
I was talking about--
if you like, when I was talking
about sharing and dividing
and so on in the context
of Jerusalem, of course,
I was not taking into account
the rest of the West Bank,
and even more, the
West Bank, Gaza
kind of geographic situation.
And of course, in the context
of the present situation,
you can't really
talk about anything.
I mean, there's nothing
really to discuss seriously,
positively, in a
positive fashion.
But what I was trying to
say was that, in a better
kind of situation, in a
better kind of climate,
it is still possible to address
the different issues that we
have.
It is mathematically possible
to adjust the different issues
that we have, whether
it's in the West
Bank or Gaza or Jerusalem.
The problem is not that it is in
itself, logically, if you like,
a puzzle that cannot be solved.
It is something
that is political.
And that is the problem with it.
It is what poses a problem
politically, but not logically,
I think.
So if the climate is changed,
and that is possible.
And what makes it possible
is what you just said.
That if you go beyond
the surface a little bit,
if you look at society, if you
look at individuals and so on,
you'll find that actually
people, at the end of the day,
are human beings.
And they often, at
different levels,
interact with one another as
equals and as human beings.
It is only when
they take on, they
put on the cloak of politics
in one situation or another
that then there is
a different dynamic.
But underneath, I think, there
are many cases, I believe,
of people really
believing that they
are equal to the other side.
I can't think of examples now.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
Sari, if I might say--
I'll give you an example.
So one good example,
I think, is this--
the Youth Orchestra of
Israeli and Palestinians.
And which gave me once the idea
of writing something to talk.
And this was a talk--
the context was
something called sound,
or sound and identity,
or space and identity.
And I wasn't sure what
to say in this context.
That's the conference
I was invited
to speak or give a talk at.
And I was sitting with
Lucy, with my wife,
at the place where there was
a Youth Orchestra, Israelis
and Palestinians.
They were about 14,
15, 16 years old.
And they were practicing
singing together.
And they were singing.
And they sang a beautiful song.
You can actually Google it.
They sang a beautiful
song called, "I
Want to Make This Your Home."
"I Want to Make This Your Home."
Now this is an Israeli
and a Palestinian--
not just, you know,
there were 10 of them.
And I liked I liked the title,
that I want to make this home.
I liked it being
sung by the Israeli,
addressed, as I imagined,
to the Palestinian.
And I liked it being sung by the
Palestinian, as I imagined it,
being sung to the Israeli.
And they were singing
it in Arabic, in Hebrew,
and in English.
And I said to myself,
you know, this is great.
This is a new sound.
And this is a sound
that is creating
a new space of identity,
an identity of sharing.
And I went home, and I worked
a lot about this, on this,
and developed a whole
sort of concept.
And went very happily
to give a talk,
and actually brought
together with me
to that talk the orchestra--
what you call them-- the--
Choir?
[INAUDIBLE]
Was it a choir?
It was a choir.
No, we showed it on--
because it was in
Hawaii, the conference--
I couldn't take
with me to Hawaii.
But he came, not
the entire group.
But it made me feel good.
It still does.
And I think you'll
find many examples
like this, which gives us
hope, which gives one hope,
gives me hope.
It is saddening, yes, that
it's taking us so long,
that it's taking so much time.
It is saddening especially
for me as a Palestinian.
Because as you probably know,
the pressure on this side,
on the Palestinian side,
is far, far, far greater
than it is on the Israeli side.
We are sort of at the
receiving end, if you like.
We live in constant anxiety.
We live in constant--
I don't know if--
I don't know myself, even, if I
am sort of fully normal by now
as a result of the pressures
that we live under.
But even so, my
hope still exists.
And I think we should
all continue to hope.
And I think if we all
hope, then you know,
we all can do something.
Let me ask you
one last question.
Then I want to show
the photographs.
And I want you to
just respond to them.
OK.
So you said a moment ago
that if things change--
and this is a very
big question--
I don't know what should change.
Should it change within
the Palestinians?
Which parties there, which
governmental structure
should change-- this we can
have a conversation about.
But I want to put the whole
issue, the Middle East issue
in the more general context,
in the context of Saudi Arabia.
In the context of the
United States where,
of course, from what you
say, Trump is very happy
trying to rethink a kind of
a federation of Palestinians.
Whereas here, you know,
Mexicans are not allowed--
children [INAUDIBLE].
I mean, so I just
consider that to be
a hideous way of displacing
what is on his doorstep.
But then you have Turkey.
You have the
problems in Lebanon,
where there are a
number of Palestinians.
But generally, this kind of--
Hannah Arendt called
tribal nationalism,
nationalism where the
leaders of the country
set themselves up as saviors.
I mean, Netanyahu does
this the whole time
with Trump's encouragement.
The enemy is not--
that they are the enemy, really.
They're the enemy.
The majority is
the real minority.
And they need to recover
everything that they've lost.
So with that kind
of world scenario,
how is it specifically affecting
the claims of the Palestinians
now?
Now?
You ask a very hard question.
I think-- let me tell you.
I mean, the Palestinians
have actually
been living in a state of
chaos in the past 10 years,
especially since the
death of Arafat, I think,
and with the lack of progress.
And in particular, in
the past few days--
you may have heard or
not, I'm not sure--
but there's been problems with
the actual structure, the PLO
structure that we've had for,
as [? our ?] representative
for many years.
But in the meantime, for some
reason, and somehow or another,
the Palestinians have
actually been able,
are able, are managing, to
bring themselves together again.
And so, for example, I was
contacted at one point a few
months ago by somebody
who came and said--
and two and three people--
to me, look, something is
wrong with the structure.
These are academics,
journalists, Palestinians,
one living in Turkey, one
living I don't know where.
But they came and said--
and one Israeli Palestinian.
And we should get together
and try and think again
of what we should be doing.
And so we started the whole
movement, if you like,
of Palestinians, Palestinians
that come from the refugee
camps in Syria,
Palestinians that
come from Europe, from
the United States,
Palestinians from Israel,
from the West Bank, from Gaza.
And they started the sort of
social media now people use.
And they've been
trying, you know.
They've been coming
together again.
And it's amazing how people can
come back and become one again.
And maybe we are just
one group among many.
But I can see that
sort of happening.
So in spite of everything
that's happened
to us, in spite of the pressure,
in spite of the defeats,
in spite of the chaos, in
spite of the entire world, led
by Trump, being against us.
I don't know why
or how, but people
seem to be able to gather their
strength together, reformulate
their structures,
their strategies,
their ways of thinking.
And so I'm not--
I haven't-- on the contrary, I
mean, I think I'm very hopeful,
Palestinian-wise, of a future
in which we will be able to live
dignified human lives in our
homeland and not, hopefully,
at the expense of anyone
else who will live with us
in equality.
And economically, you
think this is viable?
Yes.
I mean, I think economically
the entire region can change.
And economically, I think we
can look forward to prosperity
in the Arab world.
There's no reason why not.
Thank you.
No mathematical reason why not.
If politics is about
mathematics, [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Could we just have these
photographs, please?
Thank you.
So I'd just like
you to look at them.
This book was launched
just a couple of weeks ago.
And it's about--
Is it very costly?
I can get you a copy.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's the cover.
And these are all pictures
taken from her window
over a period of time--
Wow.
--which overlooks the--
you know where it is.
It overlooks the wall.
Yeah.
So these are--
And you can see the
way in which the--
because of the way the
photographs have been taken,
they have a kind of
a vertical dimension.
You know, there's a
layered dimension.
[INAUDIBLE]
I can't see the--
Why don't you and I--
oh, I see.
So this is in the
actual precinct.
Yeah.
OK.
I thought under the
gentle general terms
of sharing the
city these might be
some moments of a
certain kind of sharing
you might want to talk about.
Can we have the next, please?
No sharing here.
Yeah, third one, please.
You can hardly tell who
these people are, right?
OK?
Oh, Sari, that, by the way, is
a reflection through the window.
Uh huh.
So it's been relocated
from being out of sight
to being placed above the wall.
When we were
discussing pictures,
photographs, earlier with my
wife and daughter and my--
I think over breakfast--
and now I want to try and
remember what they were saying.
But when you have pictures
of Jerusalem, I mean,
one of the things
is that one has
to take into account is that
you are supposed to think
not only of what you see,
but of what you do not see.
So the picture has
meaning in so far--
not only as what it shows you,
but what it doesn't show you.
And so often, very
often, you will, say,
take pictures, say, of religious
Jews in the whole city, say--
many of them.
And you will see
only that picture.
And the idea there is that
you're not just seeing them,
you're not seeing
the other side.
You're not seeing the Arabs
in the old city or vice versa.
Now, in the first
photo, the photo
shows the two sides together.
So Michelle has a pleasant
way of looking at life.
I don't know, what the rest.
I mean, I like
that picture, too.
I just hope that this is the
place where something might
happen that will be
horrible, that will
be a kind of explosive.
Yeah.
Yes.
The actual precinct,
I mean, this
is the place where everything
can just blow apart.
It's the place that's
actually under--
you know, it's
what is contested.
And you know, what's
contested is not the place.
It's the narrative.
It's the history.
You know, it's the
acceptance of each other.
And I don't know if
you realize, but one
of the things that people
must be reminded, I think,
is that when the Muslims came
to that area, there was nothing.
I mean the Muslims did not
come and destroy an existing
temple, for instance--
Jewish temple.
They did not destroy anything.
It was a totally what's it.
And so 500 years later, they
came and built something.
It wasn't-- and in many
ways, they built it,
in my own opinion, as a way of
commemorating the existence--
but this is not a very
popular thing for me to say--
the existence of the temple.
In my opinion, this was
the whole idea behind it,
that this was an
affirmation of a continuity
of the Abrahamic religions.
That's why it was built. It was
not to deny the Jewish history.
It was to reaffirm
it, in many ways.
And this is, again,
what makes it sad.
That now it's the point
over which there is
this contention of narratives.
And it's where things will
be made or be broken here.
it's the--
Flash point.
It's the flash point.
Let's move to some
questions from the audience.
Yes.
Please?
What can we do [INAUDIBLE]
responding to your--
sorry.
Do introduce yourselves,
if you'd like to.
My name is [? Sophie ?]
[INAUDIBLE]..
I'm an Israeli.
I'm a scholar and scientist,
and biomedical scientist.
But involved in activism
of a pro-Israel pro-peace
organization, J Street.
But otherwise, the
question-- just what
can we do such that such
explosion will not happen?
Sari, can we take two
or three questions?
There was one somebody here.
And then there was
somebody there.
And then the three here.
And then we'll go.
And maybe people can answer
questions, as well as ask them,
please.
[LAUGHTER]
Hi.
I'm Kayleigh.
I actually lived in
Jerusalem this summer.
I was at the Mormon university
on Mount Scopus, studying.
So I was wondering about
just the legislation
that may be needed or
what your insight is
on possible legislation
needed to maybe invite
those ideas of equity
between the people, allowing
similar rights of citizenship,
especially in Jerusalem
with the residency
and everything.
Just, possibly, what
legislation is needed?
Hm.
[INAUDIBLE]
My name is [? Ghazi. ?]
I am a student--
a master's student at
the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
My question is, again, slightly
similar, slightly linked
to the picture that we
have in front, as well.
Is that, when we talk
about sharing a city,
one of the most important
things in Jerusalem
that has to be shared would be
the common religious grounds.
And one example of
religious places
that are not being
shared is Hebron,
where the mosque of Abraham
has been forcefully divided
between a Jewish quarter
and a Muslim quarter.
So I just wanted
to get your view
on how, if we do
talk about sharing
from an optimistic
perspective, would we ever
be able to share the
religious sites that
are present within Jerusalem?
OK.
What can we do?
I'm not sure what can
be done, actually.
I think the most
important thing is
to maintain the
faith in the ability
to get there at the end.
I mean, things
are so distressing
and so disappointing and so--
that you need to exercise even
more effort to try and maintain
faith in the
possibility of reaching
some kind of equitable solution.
And I think that
requires a lot of courage
and a lot of commitment,
a lot of hard work.
And to sort of try--
I'm not sure, actually.
I think there are
many things that
can be done at the level
of human interactions.
And even abroad, I mean,
maybe, to try and get
more support for a solution.
I think it's very important
for Israelis or pro-Israelis
and pro-Palestinians
abroad to try and make
peace between
themselves, for instance.
I remember, in the past, I
used to come out sometimes
with an Israeli
colleague to sort
of garner support for
a peaceful solution.
And we'd find the
audiences there,
abroad, in the
states, or somewhere,
Israeli-- pro-Israeli
or pro-Palestinian,
needing to have peace be made
among them or between them.
So I think a lot
has to be done here.
I think there has to be
encouragement for people.
People have to encourage each
other who want to make peace.
They have to continue
to encourage each other
and give hope for one another.
But I don't, sure,
you know, I don't
have any specific answers.
With legislation, you
know, we have a problem now
with the next nation
state law which
has made things even worse.
And I hope sometime in the
future it still can be changed.
It needs a lot of work
to have it changed.
So it's not just
one legislation.
I think there's a whole dynamic
there that needs to be changed.
And with the Hebron,
I think you're right.
But the most
important thing there
is to somehow come to accept
the narrative of the other.
I mean, I don't know
if you remember,
but in the case of this
particular place, there was--
Clinton came up with an idea.
I don't know-- you know, during
the talks that were rejected
at the time--
in which she sort of asked
Palestinians and Israelis
to somehow think of
dividing things up
in their minds between
what's above ground
and what's below ground,
what's in history
and what's in existence.
And it was a roundabout way
of basically saying, look,
you know, the Palestinians and
Muslims have to-- the Muslims
or whoever--
have to accept Jewish
history in this place.
This has to be recognized.
But likewise, the Jewish
people or the Israelis
have to accept now the
status quo in this place.
It's a kind of
exchange of ideas.
But I don't really know.
I'm not very sure.
But maybe we need another
messenger from God
who will come and tell us.
But you were going
to be that messenger.
[LAUGHTER]
You're not telling us.
Well, I did think, yes,
I put in an application.
[LAUGHTER]
But look, I mean--
because I mean, it
just doesn't make
any sense for those religions.
And I mean, Jerusalem,
in particular,
is just as important for
Muslims, Christians, as well as
Jews.
And they all revolve
around the same places.
And it's a question
of maybe we have
to go back to the
idea of the idea
and try to sort of, somehow,
work on the idea of religion
in the context of those people.
And maybe when we do that, it's
possible then to somehow be
open to other people, other--
yeah.
I mean, religions can be
terrible, as you know.
And you know, it's in my
case, for instance, I feel,
in particular, that--
yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah, right there.
So this may be coming from
a little bit of a dark side.
Where's the dark side?
Oh, there, Melissa.
I'm the dark side.
Melissa's the dark side.
Just because, given the
constellation of world leaders
we have right now, anything
bad can happen and does.
So from a different
perspective, two questions--
what's the worst
thing that can happen?
What would be the worst
move that would destroy
any possibility of peace?
And what would be,
on the not dark side,
what would be a situation
where the Palestinians
and the Israelis had to work
together just to survive?
So what can you imagine
bringing them together?
Like a crisis, climate change--
I don't know, something.
And then what could you
imagine is the worst thing that
could happen, for instance,
Trump and Netanyahu could do,
and what are the other guys--
the Saudi?
I don't think Trump and
Netanyahu can do things--
I mean, as such.
But what can happen
the worst thing
is a series of tragic
accidents or incidents, one
leading to the other, and ending
up with, maybe, a major effort
to expel Palestinians.
So sort of one act
leading to another,
becoming more explosive
and leading to eviction,
mass eviction of people.
And that would be
a terrible thing,
I think, a worse thing
for a long period of time.
And what can happen is if the
Palestinians and the Israelis
get together, is
if suddenly we see
Netanyahu attended by a lot of
right wing religious leaders
hugging up Hamas with leaders
and Muslim religious extremist
leaders.
I think if that
happens and people
see that, I think people
will come together again.
Sari, there's this
gentleman in green.
Could you-- oh, yeah.
All right.
Fine.
Could you just distribute
the mic as you see people.
I don't want to conduct this.
Hi.
My name is Robin.
I wanted to thank
you for coming today.
It's wonderful to hear you.
And I wanted to just address
this woman's question what can
we do.
I think the first
thing-- everything--
that was a great question.
I always think of that myself.
But I think the
first thing everybody
has to do is vote, whether
it's here or in Israel.
We've all got to vote and
make our legal representatives
accountable for what
we think is right.
But also I wanted to say that
we can support all the arts.
We see Mohammed Assaf has
been out there creating
a lot of national pride.
We've had the recent
Palestinian film
festival in Boston,
which was magnificent
and very rich representation
of the arts Boston
has a wonderful
Palestinian comedian
who communicates
with humor, love,
and tremendous national pride.
Who's that?
I can't think of
his name right now.
Do you remember his name?
I can't remember his name.
And we have the center
of Arabic culture
which often has social events
that celebrates and promotes
understanding.
And so I just wanted to say
participating and asking
ourselves what can we
do is really important.
And if you can't
remember his name,
can you remember
one of his jokes?
Not right now, I'm too nervous.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
Gentleman in the green.
We don't know what the
Trump plan is because he
hasn't presented it yet.
However, he did make
the startling statement
that the negotiations will
be easier because he's
taken Jerusalem off
the table, which
is really incomprehensible.
Rumors of the plan,
though, suggest
that it's some kind of
a rump state with Abu
Dis as its nominal capital.
And Israel, of course,
continues to refer to Jerusalem
as its undivided capital.
So I'm wondering whether
this is really a red line,
whether the protests in
Gaza or the beginnings
of a fourth intifada and
whether New Jerusalem really
is, just to be very
specific, non-negotiable.
Jerusalem is
non-negotiable for us.
We have to have
equal rights in it.
It is non-negotiable.
You're [? expecting ?]
[? a fourth ?] intifada is
on its way [INAUDIBLE]?
Gaza is under such pressure.
Gaza is under such pressure,
people living in such poverty.
They're living in such distress
that even if it explodes,
it will simply implode.
And this is what's
happening with it.
And Gaza has to be addressed
at the humanitarian level.
And it needs
emergency assistance.
It needs both Israel, as well
as the Palestinian authority
to open up, to facilitate.
[INAUDIBLE] Egypt [INAUDIBLE].
Egypt-- but you know, the
immediate neighbors and parties
that are responsible
are both Israel
and the Palestinian authority.
And the Palestinian
authority has
to look after the
people in Gaza.
And Israel has to enable
the [? EPA ?] to look
after the people in Gaza.
But no, I don't think
there's an intifada coming.
Although there's a
weekly, as you know,
there's a weekly
march, every Friday.
Yesterday, three kids 12
years old were killed.
Apparently, they
thought they were--
but I mean, they were putting
out things for catching birds,
like 12-year-olds do.
It's a distressful
situation in Gaza.
[INAUDIBLE] a primary
barrier to the resolution
of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict,
with the internal conflicts
among Israelis on the one hand
and among Palestinians
on the other, which
make the leadership challenges
extremely difficult. What hope
do you see for
progress with respect
to the internal conflicts
among Palestinians?
Because some wonder whether
there's going to be one or two
Palestinian states.
I mean, given the
rather profound division
that has at times led to almost
a civil war among Palestinians.
With still more to come,
probably, in the near future--
we didn't go into that.
But yes, I mean,
we, as Palestinians,
have a major crisis at the
moment in our leadership
as a result of failure in the
peace process on the one hand
and internal failures
on the other hand,
in addition to the major
differences between Hamas
and [INAUDIBLE] and so on.
So we have a major problem.
And we have to deal with it.
And the Israelis,
of course, do, too.
The Israelis have
a problem, I think.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
But so what's the question?
Well, the question is--
What?
For what?
[LAUGHTER]
42.
Hi.
My name is Talal [? Jabari. ?]
I'm a Palestinian diaspora.
I study at HKS.
I thought it was
really interesting,
the example that you brought
up about the orchestra
and about forging
a new identity.
And obviously, being a
Palestinian diaspora,
as I'm sure it is
for Palestinians
who live in the
Palestinian territories,
it's such a central
theme in our life.
And so I was
wondering, you know,
in forging that new identity,
what that would look like?
And if you could
elaborate on that.
And thank you for coming.
Well, thank you for coming.
But how come you're a
diaspora person if you're
a [? Jabari. ?] I
don't understand.
So--
Yes.
Go ahead.
So my dad is actually Syrian.
My mom's Palestinian.
But I first and foremost
identify as Palestinian.
That's a different story.
OK.
Well, I think that
[INAUDIBLE] will tell us
about identities and forging
identities better than I can.
But--
Not tonight
[LAUGHTER]
But I think you can start with--
it's hard when you-- it's
easier when you're talking,
say, to a friend.
And you can forge a kind
of identity between the two
of you.
And you can be anything,
and they can be anything.
And the bigger the circle--
again, this is reverting
to another wisdom,
piece of wisdom my wife was
telling us this morning--
the larger the circle, the
larger the circle of identity,
the more difficult
it is to merge.
So you have to start
small and work upwards.
And I think if you form
a group, a small group,
it can influence.
It can have ripple
effects, perhaps.
But then, as Robin
was saying earlier,
I think at the end you have
to be effective politically
by actually becoming a
politician, at least by voting.
I mean you have to vote.
But you can do far
more than voting,
You can be more
active in creating
this kind of community.
There are many communities,
Israeli-Palestinian communities
by the way that, I mean,
examples that we have
that can be built upon.
By the way, Robin, who spoke
before you is married to--
I just discovered-- someone who
is a cousin, a distant cousin.
He's a distant cousin who
was born in Syria, too.
[INAUDIBLE]
There you are.
Yeah.
Can I ask [? Lucy ?]
Nusseibeh to speak?
Because clearly, you
have been inspiring Sari
with these various
ideas all day.
[LAUGHTER]
Photographs in the
morning, circles
of identification in the
afternoon-- so could you--
and have your own NGO.
And could you add
to this discussion
by answering the good Leninist
question, what is to be done?
[LAUGHTER]
Take a step back.
I don't think I could
answer the question at all.
Thank you very much for the--
What should not be done?
--invitation.
I mean, I think I would
just add to what others
have been saying, the importance
of really reaching across
to the humanity of other people.
That part of what
seems to be going on
is this aim,
polarizing, at allowing
us to dehumanize other people.
And that it's important
to resist this.
And it's important to
resist the kind of despair
and discouragement
that is thrown at us.
The kind of resilience that Sari
actually exemplifies and was
insisting on, I
think, earlier, this
is really incredibly important.
Not just in the
Israeli-Palestinian context,
I think, but in a
more global context.
As we look around us, we
have to reach out and say no!
This is not who we are.
And this is not how we will
accept seeing other people.
We are insisting on
engaging with others
as equal human beings with total
reciprocal respect, something
like [INAUDIBLE].
Lucy, can I ask you
whether these ideas
of some kind of convergence
that you were talking
about happened at
different levels,
are there any in Jerusalem?
Are there any
state institutions,
or are there
national institutions
that give you hope?
For instance, in India, we
do have the Supreme Court.
And give or take, we have
hope in the Supreme Court
that minorities, social
justice issues will be,
not always, but quite often
welcomed and hospitably dealt
with.
Are there any institutions in--
for both of you--
in the Israel-Palestinian
confluence
that give you hope for the
future or for the present?
I think there used to be.
I can't think of
any at the moment.
There is an interesting
case recently of--
[INAUDIBLE]?
No, no, no.
But I was going to say there
is an interesting case of the--
because you know, you would
say the Supreme Court,
for instance.
But in Israel, in
particular, that
has been influenced by politics.
And so it's not as
reliable as it was.
But most recently,
for instance, there
was this case of the
American Palestinian student
who was coming in to study
at the Hebrew University.
And she was prevented from
doing so to begin with.
And actually, one of the things
that made her case stronger,
that eventually
made a difference,
was the fact that the
Hebrew University itself
and the academics there, or
a sufficient number of them,
stood up for her and
made a whole thing.
And so finally, she is now at
the Hebrew University studying.
[? Roger ?] [INAUDIBLE].
Speak without the mic?
Yeah.
We don't need mics here.
The case you've just raised
is very interesting to me
personally.
Because that young woman
was interested in pursuing
the study of international human
rights at Hebrew University,
which makes the denial of her
entry all the more poignant.
But as I understand
it, one of the facts
that counted in her favor is
that although at an earlier
point in her studies as
a student [INAUDIBLE],,
she had been a proponent of the
boycott [INAUDIBLE] sanction
that she had later
renounced that stance
and that this
counted in her favor.
I'm perhaps putting
you on the spot.
Could-- at least
among diapora Jews
who oppose current
Israeli policy,
the BDS movement is
usually seen as one
of the most divisive factors.
Friends of mine, like
[INAUDIBLE],, no relation,
apparently, who supported are
ostracized by certain portions
of the Jewish community.
And her case, in particular,
was very interesting,
[INAUDIBLE] where her
renunciation of that tactic
seems to have played a
role in her admission.
And I'm curious,
from your perspective
on the Palestinian
side, whether BDS
seems to have any
constructive role to play
or whether it's seen as largely
irrelevant to [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is putting me
on this on the spot.
It's a very difficult question.
Look, let me start
somewhere else on BDS.
Because normally, when people
talk, the Palestinians talk
about BDS, they not
only are thinking
of Americans or Europeans.
They're thinking
of Palestinians.
And they're saying basically
that, in Palestine itself,
we, the Palestinians,
should boycott
our counterparts, Israelis.
So what does that mean?
It means basically
boycotting everything--
from the economic to the
trade to the commerce to this,
to this--
right up to the
negotiation level.
This is something
that is, I think,
a thing entirely
separate from the call
for Europeans or Americans
to boycott Israel, right?
And you know, I would argue
very strongly, personally,
that the level of the
Palestinians, the thrust,
the force shouldn't be
to boycott, but to do
the opposite, to engage.
Because that is the way
to bring the Israelis
and the Palestinians
closer to one another.
Now concerning the outside,
now, I think it varies.
As far as the Jewish
community is concerned,
I think this is a situation
that has to be solved
within the Jewish community.
But I'll tell you as far as
the non-Jewish community is
concerned.
Because in the past,
I've had situations
where more than once someone
was invited to Israel
to participate in a talk at
the Hebrew University or Tel
Aviv or somewhere--
would write to me and say,
look, I've been invited.
I'm worried about this BDS.
What do you think?
And can I come and give a
talk at your university,
somehow, to sort
of balance this.
And my reaction
would have been, was,
in fact, on more
than one occasion,
that they should make
up their own minds what
they wanted to do.
But in any case, if they
decided to come and participate
in whatever, then they would
be welcome to come and give
a talk at our place,
but not to use the fact
that they are coming to give
a talk at our university
as a kind of justification
to go and talk over there.
But they have to go through
the ethical, if you like,
management processing
themselves.
They have to decide what best
fits their moral bearings.
Now has it been useful?
In many ways, the campaign
for BDS in American campuses,
in Europe, has been useful in
the sense it's raised awareness
in a way that this did not
happen before concerning
the Palestinian plight.
So there is that part of it
which you can say is positive.
On the other hand, it's
also created more friction,
whether within the Jewish
community or between the pros--
you know, the pro-Israel and
the pro-Palestinian groups.
And you see, if you're
thinking like me,
then you're thinking
you want to make--
this is a point I made earlier--
you want to make the pro-Israels
and the pro-Palestinians
actually to make peace
between one another.
That's what you want to do.
And you don't want to
create the friction.
And you need that
peace abroad in order
to support the peace within.
So how do you solve this puzzle?
You should go to
the United Nations
and ask for
intervention and to get
pro-Israelis and
pro-Palestinians
to get together.
Because the conflict
outside actually only
serves to create
more conflict inside.
Thanks.
Talking about boycotts
and academic boycotts
that you mentioned, as a
former president of Al-Quds
University, how do
you see the boycott?
If I understood well,
Palestinian universities
boycott [INAUDIBLE]
are not allowed
to collaborate with
Israeli universities.
So how do you see this?
Would you favor collaborations
of Palestinian universities?
I do.
I do is the simple answer.
I mean, I do, in fact.
But my position has been
very unpopular in the past.
[INAUDIBLE] At first, as you
say, the Council for Education,
the Palestinian Council for
Education, took a position--
this is even after Oslo--
to not to have any, to
prevent any connections
between Israeli and
Palestinian universities.
I was a member of the
Council for Education.
And I said to the
Council that I will not
abide by this decision.
And we are an
independent institution.
You want to go this way, fine.
But you know, my
way is different.
And we, in fact, did go
on and institute relations
with Israeli counterparts
all the way up to 2000--
I think, and 14,
was it-- or whenever
it was that Israel invaded
Gaza the second time.
And [INAUDIBLE] the first time.
And at that point,
it became very hard.
And I convened a meeting with
all the Palestinian academics
at my university who
were engaged in projects
with Israeli counterparts.
And I asked them how
they felt, and it
was a very emotional point,
emotional period at that time.
And after a lot of discussion,
the majority decision was,
you know, should
suspend our relations
with Israeli counterparts.
But we should look again at
this after a period of time.
But we should not stop anything
that's ongoing at the moment.
So there was that.
And after I left
the administration,
I think people at
the University have
been less enthusiastic about.
But as I was saying
earlier, I mean,
in the case of the
Israeli-Palestinian relations,
you know there are many
things you can boycott.
And I think the last
one you want to boycott
is, in fact,
academic cooperation.
I mean you can start with
the mafia on both sides.
And stop them from cooperating.
And the underworld, there's
a lot of cooperation.
And you know, and you can go--
Adelson.
Adelson, yeah.
[LAUGHS]
Academics, I think,
should be able to--
and actually, we stand to
benefit, the Palestinians,
from this cooperation.
Please.
Sorry.
You've been waiting
for a long time.
I apologize.
Thank you.
I have a question about the
whole concept of sharing.
And I wonder how it
works when one side comes
to the table holding all of
the cards or all of the oranges
or all of the cakes, and the
other side doesn't have it.
So does the concept
of sharing work there,
or is it more a matter
of giving and receiving?
And if the latter, then to what
extent does the giver really
want to give?
And to what extent does
the recipient really
want to receive?
So I have a little bit of doubt
about this notion of sharing,
although I believe
in it firmly myself.
Well, as [INAUDIBLE]
was saying earlier,
I think one of the
things you have
to do when you come
to the table is
to change who you are
sitting in front of.
So of course, I mean, I think
there's [INAUDIBLE] point
that, of course, a negotiator
or the party that is negotiating
with you has to be somehow
worked in order to begin
to see you differently.
And I think once they do
that, then it's not a matter--
it ceases to be a matter
of giving as a kind of-- it
becomes a matter of,
perhaps, a moral imperative,
or perhaps even a need.
In the case of the Israelis
and the Palestinians,
I'll tell you something that
struck me some time ago, when
I was younger.
That Shimon Peres said--
that I used very often--
at one stage, Shimon Peres
was actually trying to get--
he was talking about
the need to make peace
with the Palestinians.
This was in the '80s.
It was in the mid-'80s.
So it was before anything.
And he was making this
statement to Israelis
in his own backyard,
so to speak.
And he said something like this.
He was telling them, we
have to make an exchange
with the Palestinians.
Because it is true that we,
the Israelis, hold the present.
But the Palestinians
hold the future.
And the exchange
you have to make
is for us to give them
a part of the presence
so that they can give
us a part of the future.
This is the real exchange.
And so we the Palestinians
actually are not
weak at the negotiating table.
Yes, we don't have guns, or
we don't have enough of them.
We don't have rockets.
We don't have all of that.
But don't be mistaken.
We are very strong.
So there is a question here, and
then there's a question there.
You want a question.
That's the last question.
So one, two, yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
So the language and the rhetoric
of oranges and their sharing,
as well as the
language of sharing
in the title of the
conversation and the rhetoric,
the attendant rhetoric
of giving and exchange,
all that reminds me of
the kind of language
that is used in a
considerable chunk
of the academic literature
on Israel-Palestine.
Which really uses the language
of settler colonialism
as the basis, as
the primary basis
for making sense of
what sharing is like.
And I take the last
sentiment to be
attendant to the ways in
which a straightforward
metaphor of sharing
might not be as
attendant to the
political imbalances that
are historically
mediated and sedimented.
So my question is really
about in what ways
can we have the
historical process
and the ongoing, indeed,
historical process of settler
colonialism be central to
a conversation about going
forward?
And one way in which I've
been struggling with this is
is precisely through
the coalitions
that have been forming recently
between Jews and Palestinians
and indeed, non-Jews
and non-Palestinians
around a settler colonial
perspective that recognizes
the extent, ways in which
religion and culture play
a role, but also points
to their contingency.
And so you can have
an anti-Zionist Jew,
and an anti-Zionist Palestinian,
and an anti-Zionist humanist
working together
for a way of life,
a cohabitation that recognizes
the humanity of everyone
there in ways,
perhaps, that fall
beyond the rhetoric of sharing.
So I'm wondering
if you can speak
to the question of
language and the framework
that we've been using in
making sense of the issue.
Well, I mean, don't
forget when we
use the term sharing
in this context,
we're thinking in
terms of the existing
parameters, political
parameters which
are to do with having to
try and still make out
a case for some kind of
resolution between the Israelis
and the Palestinians on the
basis of two states, basically.
All right?
And you know, if
you cannot do that,
we're still thinking in the
context of the same parameters.
We're thinking if that's
not possible, then
how else within, again, the
existing circumstances can
we, in any case, bring about
some kind of an equitable
kind of living condition for
both Israelis and Palestinians.
Now what you're saying, in
fact, pushes a bit further.
What you're doing is
basically telling us
we should reconsider
the parameters.
And you know, the
parameters that
are being used in
the modern context
or in the existing context
do not actually work.
And you may be right.
And actually, it's
something that is--
I mean, I mentioned it
earlier-- that it's something
that does occur to one.
That maybe, for instance,
Zionism as such,
even Palestinian nationalism
as such are just as they are
and as [? they ?] become
are things that cannot
of themselves resolve into
something that as you call
humanitarian humanitarian
state of peace between people.
Well, I think we
have to work slowly.
I mean, I'm prepared to
look at my case, at my age,
I'm prepared to look at every
way people offer you to push
forward and towards peace and on
a peace that will be equitable,
that will offer
dignity and respect
for different people,
different individuals belonging
to different backgrounds.
And at the end of the
day, it doesn't really
matter very much how you get
there or what sort of theoretic
construct you use in
order to get there.
In my case, say, as a
person living in Jerusalem,
all I need is to finally
find peace at home.
Now you know whether through
this theoretic construct
or that, at the end of the
day, it's secondary for me.
But you're right.
I mean, I think
the language we use
is very much stuck to a
certain framework of politics
that we are today following.
A peace with dignity,
peace with equality--
so that's where all
the rubs come in.
If you're willing to accept some
kind of ad [? hocary, ?] then
you can get a kind of peace.
But it's not with dignity and
equality, which is your demand.
Yes, a final question, please.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
My question is kind of going off
of what Abdullah's just said,
We've talked so much about
understanding and reaching
across for that understanding.
But I haven't heard
the word responsibility
or accountability
be used so much.
And I feel like the
root of this is really
within Israeli
society to overcome
a great deal of denial of
accountability in the region.
And we're talking a lot
about recognizing each other
as human beings.
And the Israeli military's
behavior on the Gaza Strip
is not recognition of
Palestinians as human beings.
And so I want to just to
end, if you have any--
to my mind, the only
kind of route, at least,
might be within local
communities in Israel
to begin to have
these conversations,
to begin to start even talking
about the idea of settler
colonialism, which is
not discussed widespread
in the Israeli youth.
And one idea that's
applicable, perhaps,
is the idea of truth
commissions, which
has been used in South Africa.
And I wonder if you know of
any, or involved with any,
or promote any discussion
groups among the young people,
among education groups in
Palestinian communities,
or if you know of any
within Israeli communities
that adopt these kind
of values of recognition
that might overcome some of
this denial and blindness
on the part of Israelis.
Well, you know, your question
is very difficult to answer.
I mean, I don't really
know such groups.
I think that the problem
is-- is to have such groups.
I mean, the problem is
that people, as you say,
are in denial of
their responsibility.
If you think about
Israel as the soldiers
that are shooting at
the people in Gaza,
or if you think of
Israel as the occupation,
or Israel as the
colonial movement,
or you know, as the displacement
movement of the Palestinians.
And if on the Israeli side,
you think of the Palestinians
as the terrorists,
and as I don't
know what and what
and what, it's
very hard to get
either side to think
in terms of reconsidering
their self view,
their self appreciation.
And so it's sort of
going to take time
to get there to the point
where you can start,
for instance, like, commissions
that will look into,
that will accept
responsibility on the part
of the entire group.
I think it'll take a long time.
I don't know of any
that exists today.
I mean, there are
Israeli groups,
like, for instance, the soldiers
and so on who were wonderful
stories.
I mean, I was reading something
by David Schulman recently,
who is at the H University.
Something even more
interesting by a woman
called Hillerman, I
think, Dr. Hillerman.
She produced her book in
Hebrew about two years ago.
But now it's coming
out in English--
I think Chicago Press.
And I mean, you read her, and
you see that she actually--
I mean, she's accompanied
Palestinian workers.
She's accompanied
Palestinian prisoners.
She has gone to jail.
She's been in the middle
of Gaza, the middle of--
and in each and
every corner, she
is describing exactly
how she sees--
the underdog, the
Palestinians being treated,
that kind of situation.
And this kind of
testimony, I think,
is something very important.
Not only because it tells
about the Palestinians.
I think because, as I see it,
it does also about herself.
It tells about the existence of
this human spirit in the midst
of the Israeli, you know.
In this case living
in West Jerusalem.
So you just have to
have more of this.
You know, sometime, sometime
further on in the future,
maybe you'll have a
commission of human rights.
And we'll be able to.
But we're still a
long way from there.
Peter, could you just announce
Sari's next talk, please?
Yeah.
I got a technical
failure earlier.
But I hope many of you know
that Professor Nusseibeh
they will be giving a talk
this Thursday, as well.
Which I suppose
the title relates
in some ways to what
you were describing,
the hopeful image of
a possible future.
But this will address a more
academic and philosophical
theme, Are Possible Facts Real?
An Abyssinian Vignette.
And this will be this Thursday
from 5 to 7 PM in the Tsai
Auditorium, which is CGIS South.
So I hope you'll all
come to hear Professor--
But it's not about politics.
And it may be still very
boring for a lot of you.
And--
I-- want to thank Sari.
Because in fact, what you've
made us aware of in this both
despairing and at the same
time, committed conversation--
isn't there a Palestinian word
called [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
or something?
Yeah.
Yes.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
We're here.
I'm going to stay.
I'm resilient.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
With that sentiment,
I think many
of us in other
parts of the world
have to take on
that same attitude.
We live in a very, very divided,
ferociously uncaring situation
now.
And you see it in India.
You see it of course in Turkey.
In this country, where there
is plenty in some areas,
you see it at every level.
And of course, the most
ludicrous identification
of those who are out of work
with an economic fraudster who
is supposed to be the savior
or the sign of the future
just makes you baffled.
So that the things we don't
understand about the Middle
East and about that region--
there are many things we
don't understand here.
And I hope in our
mutual vulnerability
we will find both
knowledge and strength.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]